for the first time in five years
Likud members had the chance to elect
someone other than Benjamin Netanyahu as
their leader a Thursday they chose him
again solidifying his nickname as the
magician because of his ability to pull
off victory after victory Netanyahu
campaigned heavily to beat his
challenger former Interior and Education
Minister Gideon Saar
we brought about great things to the
country and in order for us to continue
bringing about great things to the
country we need to go vote for me for
you even though netanyahu is the first
sitting prime minister to be indicted on
corruption charges his popularity has
remained steady among his right-wing
base I think Tsar's tactics of sitting
on the bench and not trying to do
anything active in in the public field
is wrong I prefer people who take action
source pitch to voters was that
Netanyahu failed to form a government
twice why would he be able to reach a
different outcome a third time he warned
maintaining the status quo could mean
Likud loses power in national elections
in March SAR supporters cited concerns
over the corruption charges trailing
Netanyahu charges he calls a politically
motivated witch-hunt thus our camp has
also alleged election meddling and voter
intimidation there's a feeling of decay
in the democracy from within the party
and generally
in Israel Israel is in the midst of an
unprecedented political crisis Netanyahu
has until January first to ask the
Knesset to grant him immunity
he'll need a 61 majority vote he was
unable to get that same number of seats
to form a government in the last two
elections and on Tuesday the Supreme
Court is expected to rule if an indicted
sitting Prime Minister is allowed to
form a government
Natacha guy named al jazeera West
Jerusalem